the same courage as you showed in
Alabama we're gonna win and they're
gonna lose
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well how about that listen I need to
clarify one thing before we introduce
our final speaker for the morning I
mentioned Savannah doing a book signing
I need to clarify he will not be doing a
book signing that will be Laura Ingraham
Sebastian Gorka Todd Starnes and Everett
Piper we're all entitled to at least one
mistake per day I'm just sorry I used
mine up already so I asked for your
indulgence
well our final speaker is the most
listened to conservative female
talk-show host in the United States
that's right the Laura Ingraham show is
ranked in the top 10 radio shows in the
nation
she is also editor-in-chief and
co-founder of the conservative News
website live set calm she's a New York
Times bestselling author and her Brooks
in her books include the Obama Diaries
power to the people
shut up and sing and the Hilary Trout
but her most recent book just released
billionaire at the barricades launched
just this week ladies and gentlemen
should be doing a book signing right
after our morning session and on October
the 30th should be launching a brand-new
show on Fox News called the Ingraham
angle ladies and gentlemen please
welcome Laura Ingraham
[Music]
how you doing everybody how are you it's
great to be here it's hard to follow
Steve Bannon I mean I had the you know
III have to think of van and I think of
like force majeure you know he's a force
of nature and the man in black and I
don't know I think there's a softer side
of Steve van and that we could we could
create together think of the
possibilities like a mock turtleneck a
vineyard vines pastel I mean isn't there
a Lilly Pulitzer from man like I just
just kind of that good that Island look
just just just soften it out just a
little bit so our friends in the media
doesn't think he's so mean wouldn't that
be nice
I saw Roy Moore yesterday speak
yesterday right he was here now let me
just say after watching him if Roy Moore
wins that Senate seat of course he's
going to he's gonna make Ted Cruz look
like Jeff Flake my god this morning I
don't know if you guys saw the press you
guys have all been here but according to
the I guess it's the AP report he's
blockaded himself in statuary hall at
the Capitol and he's chained himself to
the robert e lee statue that's
incredible i love that is that great so
more is already you know I think that
and I just have one more thing to say
about about this is a little lightening
up here I guess things can be these
gonna be depressing if you follow
politics and I'm of the view and I'm
gonna try to do this on Fox every night
I love the view that we all need to have
fun while we're in this battle for
America note I think it's fun it's fun
to win it's fun to win and it's a it's a
great joy to be able to spend a little
time with you today and I was thinking
about you know the poor Democrats
everyone's talking about Donald Trump
and the divided party you know ban and
got into that I'll get into that a
little bit more but the poor Democrats I
mean they're having a Dickens of a time
doing fundraising have you seen this
they they're now trying to incentivize
donors and get you know they need the
small content and you know contributions
coming and and so forth so for $25 I
guess now the DNC you get this you know
frisbee thing they send it to you in the
mail and for 50 bucks you get a you get
a we got it we love you Hillary still
t-shirt
[Applause]
for $100 you get a subscription lifetime
subscription to mother jones i think
that's going out of business but you
still get the subscription and this is
what i find most interesting that the
DNC is doing they need more bundlers you
know if you raise $150,000 you called a
bundler so if you sign up to be a
bundler and you're really aggressive
about it I guess now the DNC has
announced this was yesterday they will
send you a terrycloth robe that opens
easily in the front it's odd though all
that robes have HW as the initials at
the monogram I think we have to laugh
don't you you know yeah they always say
we're judged by the company we keep and
that's it that's a pretty good line it's
a pretty good rule of thumb but I also
think we should judge ourselves on the
enemies we make think about the
Republicans who supported Donald Trump
and continued to support his populist
agenda the agenda that I outlined in
billionaire at the barricades my new
book it's a nationalist agenda you heard
Steve talk about it it's it's America
first it's policies that work for the
people but think about it if you're for
Donald Trump and you're for that agenda
not the old Republican agenda but that
agenda your enemies are the following
they've declared war on you and Tifa you
know the the fascist group they call it
anti-fascist but it is most fascist la
raza the NFL anthem squatters they don't
much like you since when did kneeling
become I didn't understand the protest
why is kneeling even a bad thing if
they're kneeling at the end time you
could say this maybe they actually just
like the anthem a lot like when you
kneel it's a sign of respect I don't
even understand their protest most of
the press corps they're of course ant
against us most of the entertainment
industry because we know they are the
moral arbiters of our time the Democrat
machine still run by the previous
administration and of course not let's
not free
the never Trump globalist GOP and the
consultancy and pundit class including
by the way on Capitol Hill all those
senators who if their primaries were
held today in their home state they
would be sent packing
speaking of there before a blues leave
this topic there is some good news out
there there is great news actually this
is New York Times finally speaking of
the Weinstein mess in Hollywood there's
finally a new law firm that has formed
to give Gloria Allred run for money and
she represents a lot of these women who
have been abused and subjugated in the
workplace and it's just just formed it's
gonna be a big deal it's called Clinton
Weiner Spitzer and Weinstein has a nice
ring to it don't you think let's not
forget how conservative women have been
dismissed and demeaned and reviled by
all the right people all the right
adversaries perhaps Hillary Clinton
Michelle Obama who said we voted for
Trump because we do what we're told to
do now everyone who knows me would know
that that wouldn't really apply but I
think you but what about all those
workshops and all of those seminars that
Hillary and Michelle convened about girl
power and and you know girl first and
you know we got to support women now
doesn't matter what your views are you
know at the same time I was thinking
maybe Hillary should rename her book
tour should be called I am woman hear me
bore they're so exposed right they were
never for they were never for women of
different political viewpoints they are
for you women if you agree with them
liberals if you are a woman who truly
thinks for herself and is not cowed or
or frightened because of the kalam need
being too
directed your way then frankly you don't
really deserve protection they don't
really care about you and they will
ridicule you and usually in front of a
university setting or in some general
session of left-wing malcontents I
titled my new book billionaire at the
barricades for a reason the subtitle is
the populist revolution from Reagan to
Trump Donald Trump has a lot of walls to
clear and one wall to build he has the
old GOP guard that never really wanted
him to succeed of course he has a an
entertainment industry that really
should be sending him residuals because
apparently they can't write a joke that
doesn't include his name he's up against
the Democrat machine of course that is
fueled by groups like the American
Association of trial lawyers Planned
Parenthood and every other left-wing
interest group that you can think of
he's against the bipartisan cabal that
has gotten fat and happy off the old way
they became very comfortable in a
Washington that didn't represent the
people and the people are on to them the
American people whether in this moment
they like Donald Trump or not the
American people I think are really smart
that's the reason I describe myself as a
conservative populist I would rather
like Donald Trump trust the people to
run their lives rather than a far-flung
bureaucracy at the World Trade
Organization or the UN or some
government agency that will never be
accountable to you I trust the American
people the government works for them not
the other way around the government is
not enslaving the people the government
are supposed to be the servants of the
people
period
people asked me like well you know why
Laura is this a big rift in the
Republican Party and I explained all
this from my days as a young 22 22 year
old working in the Reagan administration
and how he inspired my generation and so
many who came after all the way up until
we gave Eric Cantor a two-by-four across
the electoral face with Dave Pratt in 20
and 2014 I explained I explained how
this he Donald Trump he didn't win
because of Comey or even because Hillary
was a bad candidate he didn't win
because he was a celebrity or even that
he was self-funded Donald Trump won
because he was unafraid to hold up a
mirror to the failures of the bipartisan
establishment that refused to do what
the people for really a couple of
decades had been demanding that they do
that's why he won he won because of the
issues who voted for open borders who
voted to D industrialize the Midwest who
voted to send millions of our jobs to
Asia and other countries who voted for
perpetually low wages for our middle
class and low entry entry level position
workers who voted to completely upend
the understanding of gender in the
United States who voted for any of this
the answer is none of us voted for this
we voted for candidates along the way
who promised to do our will and respect
the Constitution that is what we did
because we tended to give people the
benefit of the doubt and like you know
Lucy in the football we kind of became
Charlie Brown election cycle after
election cycle until we couldn't take it
anymore
our back was about to break we saw the
country was about to be lost forever
Donald Trump understood that uniquely
and he followed in the line of others
who came before however from going all
the way back to Richard
Nixon and believing that we have to we
had to listen to the silent majority to
law and order - all the way up to Ronald
Reagan's surprising a GOP establishment
in 1976 by almost winning the nomination
and then coming coming along like a
hurricane himself in 1980 and blowing
past the bushes and everyone else who
ridiculed him demeaned him and said he
was just an actor he didn't know
anything he shook up the country he
brought us back from the brink
he helped defeat the Soviet Union and he
set a blueprint a conservative
oftentimes populist blueprint for how to
appeal to a wider range of Americans I
went back and in the book I described
what happened in 1988 as Reagan was
leaving office mr. just to show you this
divide wasn't created by Donald Trump
divided has been there 1988 as as Reagan
was leaving office a lot of us
Reaganites were going on to do other
things I was going to law school at the
University of Virginia and some of my
colleagues wanted to stay and help the
Bush administration well they didn't
know that slowly but surely the Reagan
people would be purged from the ranks of
the new Bush administration and why
would they be purged and I described a
particular incident at the Department of
Justice which is disturbing
why were they purged because
philosophically Reagan was on a
different plane then than George HW Bush
he respected him he picked him as a vice
president but Reagan uniquely understood
the heart and soul of the American
working class he understood that without
social conservatives and defense hawks
and libertarians and the populace all
together this coalition would crumble
and indeed we saw it beginning to
crumble in 1992 who came along then of
course well pitchfork Pat Buchanan with
many of the same issues we're talking
too gay today warning that if we had
open borders and trade agreements that
did not benefit the American working
class that the American the American
understanding would itself be endangered
as more people thought the system just
didn't even work anymore didn't work for
them didn't work for their their kids
that in fact they were being treated as
the enemies of the government pat
buchanan ultimately wasn't successful
but let's not forget whether it was him
or ross perot boy did they did they
garnered a lot of support and did they
set the stage for what would come all
those years later with donald trump
remember even george w bush ran on a
humble foreign policy in 2000 that was
welcome welcome news to the voters at
the time in 1988 the cato institute
wrote a long article ridiculing ronald
reagan now i like a lot of the folks at
cato are like a lot of the stuff they do
on taxes and the deregulatory stuff but
they branded reagan and know nothing
protectionist on trade why ronald reagan
thought it was worthwhile to save an
american company called harley-davidson
he believed that it was well within our
right in protecting our people and our
businesses to slap a 45 percent
temporary tariff on cheap Japanese
motorcycles that came in to the United
States and lo and behold we have one of
the most successful American companies
still in business today because of what
Ronald Reagan did at that moment to save
that American company that was wildly
popular it was a populist Ronald Reagan
that was the protectionist around what
since what is it bad to be a
protectionist by the way what you are
protecting something right you are
conserving something Republican
presidents throughout our history
understood that there will be certain
times where temporary tariffs are
necessary to level level the playing
field in the international marketplace
just make sense when when our companies
are getting hammered overseas with
tariffs and and barriers we just let
everyone come here with the with the
nary a peep and certainly the the the
mood and the establishment of the GOP
was very anti anti anti tariffs Ronald
Reagan said doesn't have to be this way
even George W Bush slapped temporary
tariffs on cheap cold rolled steel
coming in from China today all these
years later
is Donald Trump doing Donald Trump is
assembled without a doubt the most
impressive the most qualified trade team
that we've ever seen in American
government the most incredible people
they don't get much credit by the way
and I'm gonna repeat all this stuff that
Bannon said about about the issues that
we all care about on this issue
bobwhite Heiser was the deputy US Trade
Representative I think the youngest in
American history for Ronald Reagan he is
now our US Trade Representative he is
phenomenal phenomenal I think for the
first time in decades
we now have light hyzer and Wilbur Ross
at commerce is helping Stephen Vaughan
is the is a general counsel over there
we have mazing people
Peter Navarro at the White House they
are doing something called I don't want
to sound wonky here but a 301
investigation on China it's under the
Federal Fair Trade Act in the 1970s it's
a 301 investigation into the theft of
American intellectual property that's
being done on a daily basis by China
we got Chinese cheap imports stealing
our intellectual property american-made
and Genuity taking it pirating it making
it overseas sending it here everything
from from from pharmaceuticals to
Cambria countertops which I understand
they're they're stealing the VIP on the
quartz countertops in cheap stuff that's
probably poisoning us Trump
administration said not going to get
away with that not going to do it the
Korean free trade deal NAFTA all of
these agreements need to be revisited
re-examined and if necessary rewritten
and if they don't agree with the
rewrites on the other side repealed
that's what has to happen Donald Trump
has done more in ten months for social
conservatives then I believe our the
previous GOP president did in eight
years what did he do the Mexico City
policy gone funding abortions overseas
Neil Gorsuch one of the most qualified
people I could conceive of being on the
Supreme Court he's expanded religious
liberty in the United States by opening
up the number the the types of groups
that will be exempt from the Obamacare
contraception mandate and let's not
forget his first foreign trip which
again he gets no credit for visiting all
three major religions the sights that
represent all three major religions from
the Middle East and gathering together
all of those Muslim nations saying we've
got to have a Reformation we need your
help it's going to be in your hands to
visiting
Pope Francis and of course going to
Israel this this this trip set the stage
for the type of president I believe he
can be and he will be that should be
welcome news to all the social
conservatives listening to me across the
United States and in this room
and I was proud to march at the at the
annual March for Life this year in
January and I was I was so heartened and
I was we were all so happy who were
there hundreds of thousands of people to
actually have our vice president address
the March for Life live not on a
videotape
he was live and he was there talk about
inspiring the Democrats have a policy of
resistance they don't really have an
agenda for America and I would say
unfortunately that affliction also can
be found in the Republican Party where
if you ask the average person on the
street you know what are the political
parties trying to do in Washington what
are the Democrats about and then he said
what are the Republicans about it's kind
of confusing to people I I think the
simplicity and the clarity of messaging
is so important both at the White House
and on Capitol Hill right now we know
what this administration wants to do
it's two words America first very clear
what are we gonna do what are we gonna
do in foreign policy put America first
what are we gonna do an immigration
policy put America first trade policy
America first social policy put America
first the culture wars with what we saw
the national anthem America first from
from trade to foreign policy to
immigration to all the issues in between
we can understand where the Trump
administration wants to take us he's
doing his best under very difficult
circumstances he's not a perfect person
you're not gonna get everything right
neither do any of us but time and time
again you will see that this
administration is going to give voice to
those who haven't had a voice in many
many years the silent majority strikes
again
we've been kicked to the curb for too
long we've been demeaned and we'll be
demeaned as time goes on it doesn't
bother me one bit
I'm looking forward every night on Fox
News to be telling a broader story about
America will hit the political topics of
course will have plenty of conflict but
there's so much goodness in our country
that I see on a daily basis that I think
it's incumbent upon us as we take
seriously our role as conservative
warriors but it's incumbent upon all of
us to remind the broader American public
of what is innately so positive and so
blessed about this country from every
level from the local level to our to our
schools to teachers who are doing a
great job to those who give and
sacrifice and never make it on YouTube
I'm gonna be telling those stories
I'm gonna be telling you our stories
politics and the rest of life everything
in between
I hope you'll tune in every night at
10:00 p.m. we're gonna have a lot of
surprises in the first few weeks we're
gonna have a lot of fun I'll need your
prayers as I pray for you I pray for our
country I pray for the wisdom of our
leaders we must be we must be happy
warriors I will I will pledge to you I
will do my very best as time goes on as
I did to try to frame this election
cycle in the broader historical context
and I will do this every day every night
on the radio on television and as I
continue to write I'm so proud of what
the Values Voter Summit has done and I'm
so proud of all of you for never giving
up never giving in and always remember
what Ronald Reagan told me as I walked
out of the Oval Office for the very last
time
he said Laura make it matter thanks
everybody I appreciate it I'll be
signing books
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
c-span's Washington Journal live every
day with news and policy issues that
impact you coming up Sunday morning Tea
Party Patriots co-founder Jenny Beth
Martin discusses her group's call for
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
to resign Politico climate and energy
reporter Emily Holden on the EPA's
decision to roll back the Obama
administration's clean power plan and
former CBS and NBC chief diplomatic
correspondent and author Marvin Kalb
talks about his new book on Russia and
communism be sure to watch c-span's
washington journal live at 7:00 Eastern
Sunday morning
join the discussion on newsmakers Utah
congressman Rob Bishop chair of the
Natural Resources Committee talks about
his bill to limit the president's
ability to create national monuments
disaster aid for Puerto Rico and
wildfires in the West and other issues
newsmakers Sunday at 10:00 a.m. and 6:00
p.m. Eastern on c-span
everything was devastating for him at
the end he was really in some ways
isolated and alone Sunday night on Q&A
author and professor emeritus at Amherst
College William tockman and his
biography Gorbachev well he trusted the
Russian Peet the Soviet people he
trusted them to follow him where they'd
never gone before
that is to democratize their country in
a few short years he trusted them to
follow him as he moved the country
toward a market economy from a command
economy he trusted him he trusted them
to follow him and trust him as he made
peace in the Cold War against the
ancient enemy the United States so he
trusted them too much it turned out
Sunday night at 8:00 Eastern on c-span
Q&A
now Colorado's first Latina House
speaker and the president of Planned
Parenthood join a discussion on the
resistance to trump administration
policies from the annual Texas Tribune
festival in Austin
it's an hour
hello my name is Jamelle Bouie I'm
slates chief political correspondent and
at political analyst for CBS News and on
behalf of the Texas Tribune I am
thrilled to welcome you to the seventh
annual Texas Tribune Festival and to
this panel on Trump and the resistance
we have a terrific lineup of panelists
as you can see as I'm sure you all know
but first we need to introduce them real
quick to my immediate left is Cecile
Richards
I feel like my next two sentences
totally prettiest but if you don't know
Cecile is president of the Planned
Parenthood Foundation Federation of
America and the Planned Parenthood
Action Fund she's been a tireless
fighter for reproductive rights and in
2011 she led the national fight to save
federal funding for Planned Parenthood
so next to Cecile is Crisanta Duran she
is the Speaker of the Colorado House of
Representatives she has represented
she has represented her district in
central Denver since 2010 she was
Majority Leader for the 2015 and 2016
sessions and was elected speaker in 2016
as well that same year just going
gangbusters in 2016
Crisanta was a recipient of emily's list
writing star award next we have DeRay
McKesson
[Applause]
really really exciting DeRay was on the
ground in Ferguson Missouri when it
erupted in protest over the death of
Michael Brown since then he has been at
protests around the country protesting
police violence and in 2015 he joined
other activists and advocates in the
founding campaign zero a really
remarkable effort to end police violence
and they've Azrael Evan Azra is
co-founder and executive director of the
indivisible project before indivisible
he worked as a surgery director of
federal policy for prosperity now and he
also served as deputy policy director
for congressman lloyd doggett so a
couple quick notes this panel will last
about 60 minutes it will include a 15 to
20 minute Q&A at the end we're going to
do Q&A a little differently this time
around no one's gonna come to a
microphone instead you will submit your
questions to the Texas Tribune and I
will get your questions and read them to
the panel to submit your questions you
can either tweet with the hashtag ask
trib ASX t RI b or you can text ask trib
two five one two five four nine eight
four five zero and I'll repeat that text
ask trib two five one two five four nine
eight four five zero
we'll get the questions and then I'll
sort through them and post them to our
panelists so let's just jump into this
because panels always go much faster
than you think they do
Cecile I think we all know what the
resistance to the Trump administration
is what that means and so I'm interested
in kind of going beyond the surface
level to talk a little bit about the
term itself when we say resist
are we simply speaking about working to
prevent the worse the Trump
administration can do or are we also
talking about of advancing a positive
agenda does the word resist sort of
obscure maybe even some of the work
that's actually happening yeah thanks
Jamel and it's so great to be a panel of
folks who are not only resisting but
persisting and was one of my favorite
thoughts is that it's not just we're
going to fight back but we're gonna
we're going to move forward and I know
for us a planned parenthood and I'm here
to actually fund
and I'm sure that others have had the
same experience we gained more than a
million new supporters just it's just
right after the election and so the
whole idea now is not to simply again
fight back on the worse things like the
Graham caste bill and anyone who thinks
this thing is dead it's not dead so
you've got to call your member of the
United States Senate but I think the
idea is to use this as I know folks have
described it as sort of a movement
moment I feel like there's never been a
better opportunity as organizers to
build what is a much longer hall fight
back for the things that we believe in
and one of the things that I also think
is exciting and why being on this panel
is really exciting is that folks are
coming into these movements now and I
think rejoining or starting new things
with a much broader sense of what it
means to be part of a part of a
progressive movement and because we know
what Planned Parenthood that even though
we're fighting you know to protect
access to reproductive health care
reproductive rights we're also proud to
stand with the dreamers we're proud to
stand on racial justice we're proud to
stand for voting rights because all of
these issues affect our patients they
affect our staff they affect our
families and that to me has been one of
the better things a little bit a long
way to go about what the movement I've
seen since the election of 45 I like to
pose a question to the rest of the
panelists the resistance is it is does
include positive action of a forward
moving agenda I think an absolutely can
have a forward moving agenda I think one
of the key issues is is it is more
important than ever for people to be
involved with the political process and
it's because of the work of people
calling their senators or Congress
people about health care about daca
about so many of the issues that are
under attack now that is what we are
going to need to make sure that we keep
on going to forward into the right
direction but it happens not just with
communication with elected officials it
also has to happen at the ballot box in
2018 and 2020 we have incredibly
important elections and so if we can
continue to make sure that momentum goes
in the right direction I think that we
can make sure that we have the right
people in office you know it feels like
too
for so long in this country when it
comes to racism sexism casting people
out because they are different than what
we perceive ourselves to be that we are
seeing some of the things are being said
and done in a very / way and in such an
over way it's one of the first times in
my lifetime that we have seen some of
the things that are happening but in all
of the darkness of the conversations and
the actions I think the light is making
sure that we are coming up with a new
path forward to address those issues
head-on and that we're supporting
leaders that are willing to address
those issues head-on I'd say three
things one is that we know that freedom
is not only the absence of oppression
but the presence of justice and joy and
like just getting rid of the bad stuff
just getting rid of the bad stuff
doesn't actually just make you free
automatically that we actually have to
build a fruit a future proactively now
when Trump says make America great again
that that ask is about a recall and
remembrance we have lived in a world
before white people have controlled
everything and terrorized people and
that's not a hard world to imagine
because we've had that before but a
world of equity and justice is a world
that we don't know right like that's a
world that we have not ever experienced
so our task is about deep imagination
that that has to be a core part of our
work that when we tear down all the bad
things that we don't want somebody
somebody on our side has to be there to
build up things and the last thing I'll
say is that it's been interesting in
this past year to see people so
proactively
talk about the beauty of protests
because I remember we were in the street
in 2014 people did not think the
protesters were amazing people and how
is that this small meeting with holder
and holder was like Turay you know the
protesters are out there and I'm like
where were you at in 2014 but it's been
interesting because now that Trump has
implicated way more than marginalized
people right like so many more people
are implicated in this moment they're
people who believe that the history of
injustice in this country began with the
Muslim ban and that is wild to us right
that like this country has a deep
history of injustice and part of the
work of resistance is also remembering
that this is deeper than this moment
that Trump is he
not the originator of this he's just
like the embodiment of it in this moment
so we fight him but we fight an ideology
that's bigger than him so there's
something really unfair both having to
follow to raise comments and his and his
fancy sake nice but so I would just
reiterate a lot of what's already been
said one thing you know we we came out
with a Google Doc nine months ago and
that's all we thought it was going to be
what we've seen from the resistance is a
ton of people who have woken up they
have seen that there is injustice in
this country imagine that but we need to
recognize for these folks who are brand
new to this resistance that the
resistance isn't 9 months old the
resistance history is saying has been
going on for years or decades and part
of the responsibility of folks who are
newly engaged in this activism is to
work with those groups who have been
fighting communities across the country
to actually resist yes this new attack
on not just progressive values but basic
tenets of American democracy separate to
you to your specific question can there
be some kind of proactive agenda you
know one one thing that we wrote in the
guide is look there's a hard truth we
don't have the house the center of the
presidency we don't have agenda setting
palette right now what we have is the
power to respond now that power is not
the only power if we're going to have
there needs to be somebody out there
that's building the bolt progressive
vision the firt of the future so when we
do tear down all this negative stuff
that's out there and have an opportunity
build we know what we're building so
absolutely that's got to be a part of it
but we have to recognize that 32 million
Americans are going to lose their health
insurance if Graham Cassidy gets passed
next week and that is the urgent threat
right now that we need to respond to
[Applause]
so it's sort of a around that issue so
the kind of direct protests that
indivisible for example does is very
effective at challenging a piece of a
concrete piece of legislation like
Graham Cassady there's a lot of great
work done against the better care
reconciliation act over the summer but
the Trump administration isn't just
legislation coming out of Congress it's
a whole swath of things it's executive
orders its administrative stuff so what
and this is a question for you as for
what what does one do how does one
resist that the the aspects of the Trump
administration of the Trump agenda which
actually are kind of insulated from
popular protests yes so I would say the
Trump administration's agenda isn't even
just the Trump administration's agenda
it comes out of a long line of GOP push
priorities that have culminated in this
overall assault so it exists in the
legislature that's not Trump who's
pushing through Graham Cassidy be clear
that is members of Congress and Trump's
agenda largely depends on not Trump but
other elected officials so there is a
question how do we resist in Congress
how do we resist at the state and local
level so there are some administrative
actions through HUD through HHS through
any of the federal agencies that you
know bottom line is a constituent you
don't have much power to resist that
specific action the fact the matter is
Trump doesn't care what you think
but your independent elected officials
do care whether they're GOP or
libertarian or democratic in the State
House in the Senate in the in the
governorships they do respond to you
because they have to get your votes for
reelection so I think the question when
Trump's administration actually know
laterally to assault us is where is our
leverage how can we resist this and
sometimes it's through Congress
sometimes it's through the Statehouse
sometimes it's through the governorship
sometimes it's through corporate
pressure there are a lot of ways to
resist resist I think the question isn't
where that attack is coming from it's
what you can do as a constituent with
your power I think yeah I'd like that
let me hear you in this cuz I feel like
this is a particularly violent which is
both diffuse and it's not it's not
always clear that this is the
you know line of accountability yeah I
would say like I said before the Trump
is not the he's not the producer he's
he's not the product he's a he's not the
producer he's a product right that like
this is an ideology that's much bigger
than him in this moment and what's sort
of interesting about how we fight is
that in organizing we often organizer on
what I call loud trauma so like broken
bodies we organize our own broken bodies
we organize around the stuff that is the
biggest but the quiet trauma actually
has a huge impact on people's lives so
what does it mean all these sort of
mid-level judges that Trump is
appointing across the country that will
be there for the next 50 years or like a
real nightmare or des Vosges is clearing
out the entire backlog of civil rights
violations that is a nightmare for
people all across the country and the
police you know me we met with President
Obama twice and the thing about the
police is that there are 18,000 police
departments so the DOJ they can do some
stuff around money but most of the
changes will happen at the local level
which does create like a different
challenge run organizing and part of the
work is understanding that protest is
not the answer but protest creates space
for the answer and what the indivisible
is done with so many groups have done
and sort of pushed and opened up people
to think about the issues deeper so then
they go in their neighborhoods and
they're like okay I can do this I can do
this like people don't realize that like
in 19 cities across the country it's
more like more likely to be killed by a
police officer than a private citizen
that is wild or like us people what a
felony is and most people think that
felonies are like everybody blew up a
building killed 50 people like that is
like what felons are to people and in
Virginia if you steal something or depth
over $200 is a felony you lose your
right to vote permanently that is a wild
thing in Chicago it's theft over $300
right so how do we help people
understand that there's so much of the
what I call quiet trauma happening at
the local and state level and even the
federal level that they can actually
fight back against immediately you is
there a way to connect people who are
they're either getting into activism
because of Trump to begin to connect
them to these broader thing because I
still think I still see this from my
perspective people recognizing me can
see the direct kind of threat of Trump
but all this all this stuff is quiet
trauma is a little obscure to their
vision yeah I think that I will say that
I think that was not what the organizing
community is not done well in the past
two
three years is sort of meet the interest
so there's way more interest to do
whatever then there's ever been in like
the organizing infrastructure to absorb
that interest I think like hasn't
materialized in the way that people
wants I think everybody's sort of trying
to figure out how to do that I won't say
that people often forget that like we
all started as like random people who
believed in a better world right
they made a Google Doc I was sitting on
my couch like you know we all were like
just regular people and people have this
idea that we got here by some like a
Harriet Tubman tapped all of us and was
like you know it was like people sitting
down being like I think the police you
in contract like the organizers in
Austin they're like I think this is
wrong let me do something and they do
something and like it doesn't work and
it does work and it does work and it
does work like that's how all good
organizing actually begins and people
don't see that enough can I add some
woods there's something magical that
happens when you get dozens or hundreds
or thousands of people together to focus
on their member of Congress or one
immediate injustice and it's that pretty
soon they start thinking well wait why
don't I focus on city council or why
don't I focus on state ledger why don't
I get involved in this other community
activism that's out there we've seen
this I mean an indivisible Austin it's
an incredibly strong group and a side
group spun off in order to focus on the
state LED because they were focused on
their members of Congress but they saw
they could have impact over here so I
think if there is a a magical tool that
we have it is getting people in person
together in a room to figure out how to
make the world a better place like Garre
said oh it just a tee up that I think
there's one thing that we've got I think
about as organizers is we're not going
to a lot of these we're not gonna win so
we've got to claim victories when we
have it and like for people to begin to
kind of get that muscle memory of like
when you fight back you may not win
immediately but eventually maybe justice
comes or a little bit of justice and I
think there's no better example than
what happened here you say like getting
a you know hundred people in a room
while getting thousands of people into a
state capitol and taking over the State
Capitol those folks did during Wendy
Davis is full of us
organizing lesson and all that it's like
we never had to vote there was
absolutely no way it didn't matter how
long people say the people stayed till
2:00 and 3:00 in the morning just to try
to testify right and they never gave up
and even though Wendy won the filibuster
then they went back and but here's what
happened is people never quit and so
folks in Texas even though they passed
these horrible bills women started
telling their stories and doctors
started telling their stories and then
frankly the Texas Tribune started
telling these stories and all of this
kept going and they documented the harm
to women and two or three years later we
overturn these bills in the Supreme
Court of United States of America that's
what persistence to me is it's not just
resistance it's basically never never
giving up and I think there's great
opportunity and state legislatures and
at the City Council level across the
country right now in Colorado we've been
able to be quite productive we actually
had a package of bills has been focused
on building trust between law
enforcement and communities of color and
I think that there are ways to thread
the needle to be able to get diverse
stakeholders to be able to support
legislation and so the outcome of that
is that chokeholds are been in most
circumstances we've also done things so
that there's live videotape when
somebody is being interrogated and most
situations and so we're really focusing
on how can we bring people together to
make sure that there is a right kind of
change but we also have to think of what
is the lens that different legislators
and people and positions of power
look through you know right now in
Colorado there's been a focus on can
local law enforcement can their budget
actually be able to sustain the costs
that it would need to enforce a federal
immigration law absolutely not
are there other ways that we can think
about arguments that will bring
different people from different
backgrounds to the table to be able to
advance so many of the issues that are
the people of our state and our country
care about and make sure that everybody
is looking through a lens of fairness so
one question and I had this is for you
Crisanta because a because your lawmaker
and b-because I think it's just kind of
been a little bit in the background and
it involves Congress but I think it's
relevant in general and that is when
President Trump revoked or said he would
revoke the dream doctor I thought the
DREAM Act puts a river broke daca
immediately congressional Democrats
began looking for some sort of solution
some way to cut a deal with Trump and
they cut sort of a subordinate deal
about the budget and about disaster
funding but there's also the prospect of
a deal a permanent solution on daca and
one interesting thing since then has
been that president Trump's approval
rating has gone up it's jumped up a
couple points and there's you know you
can pretty good pick case to make that
be public spectacle of Trump working
with Democrats do something
constructively helped him out so my
question is when do do Democrats do
people who identify with the resistance
do they take the opportunity to work
with the administration if at all pretty
presents itself to accomplish something
constructive knowing that there's a
chance it may actually make the
longer-term goal of kind of getting
beyond Trump a little more difficult I
think we have to do what is right and I
had the great honor of carrying the bell
Colorado asset so that undocumented
students would be able to get in-state
tuition in Colorado it was the seventh
time that the bill had been introduced
and was finally passed but what it comes
down to is this is that when we see
someone like Donald Trump making attacks
on that community whether it be
rescinding a daca or whether it be
pardoning Joe Arpaio somebody who is
known for racial profiling there is no
doubt that we need to be able to respond
to those but one of the great errors I
think of the Republican Party was during
the Obama administration when year after
year after year they were the party of
no and no matter what President Obama
did no matter what he was trying to
accomplish for the American people
they always attacked it attacked it and
they went after it the Affordable Care
Act is a perfect example of that I mean
that was based in many parts
on a Republican based model and so when
there are opportunities to do good I
think that we have to find those
opportunities and be able to make sure
that we are driving policy that has a
good outcome from out people but that
said even if the Republicans are able to
actually get it together and do
something on immigration reform or daca
there have been so many issues that
people just feel like they have been
under attack and and in all of this we
also always have to be focused on
working people in this country you know
there are too many communities that have
been left behind
I have never bounced back after we have
had a globalized economy and when we are
fighting for equity when it comes to
race and sexism and all these other
issues we can never forget that the road
to the White House the ROA two different
leadership positions will go right
through middle-income families and are
we doing everything in our power to make
sure that people have tools to succeed
to be able to provide for themselves and
for their families that is a question we
should always be asking do you have a
take on this yeah
the do you meet with Trump question is
like a is like a real question right
because a part of it is like do you have
to tell your bully to stop bullying you
like is that your job to sit down with a
bully and be like don't hit me anymore
it's like somebody should probably tell
the bully doesn't need to be you right
there is something though about if we
can win because we are trying to change
real people's lives in a beneficial way
that like we should do that I think
about this moment like I think about the
Hillary campaign is that it's a failure
right now of having somebody on the Left
who's just like the consistent voice and
the consistent response because he
really cares about how he looks in
public like that Steph Curry tweet this
morning if any of you saw like his ego
is so fragile and there's not really a
response from the left it's like a
consistent sort of voice it's not the
DNC right now somebody else in the party
I guess it's Maxine Waters she's holding
it down for like
but I think that I think that that is a
real need is that so you see Schumer and
Pelosi go in the room and then he sort
of plays on the next day and there's not
like one person who's like holding down
sort of the message and you know Obama's
right in the book so you know he's not
doing it and I think that that is like a
real you think about the Hillary
campaign it was sort of the same thing
it's like we know killer Mike was out
there for Bernie people didn't even know
who killer Mike was you know Katrina
Pierson she was out there for Trump I
had never seen Katrina Pierson before my
life it's like who was delivering
Hillary's message I really know and like
I supported Hillary in the end like you
know but it was a question of like who's
honing the message and I think that the
right has mastered the message it's like
an awful message it's not about people's
lives like it's bad but they have like
nailed it in and then we're like you
know we just well health care and it's
like what's the other message right like
how do we like make that deeper yeah so
yeah I'd like to talk about talking
about this deal specifically that was
cut earlier this month and we so when we
wrote the indivisible guide
I remember the week that was we did have
when we decided we really just need to
do this in the news there was talk from
a Trump Lackey this is back in November
at Trump Lackey was talking about the
Japanese internment camps in a positive
light as an example of a model for
policy and in the same week we heard
Democratic leadership talking about how
we needed to cut a deal on
infrastructure and the idea that we
could wind up in a world where we have
internment camps move we got a few roads
belts was atrocious to us and scary that
we needed Democrats the standard for
progressive values that that was part of
the answer for 2017 this is why it was
called indivisible the idea that you
might be a tax advocate you might be a
reproductive rights advocate and
immigrant rights advocate of racial
justice having it but if you wait your
turn to stand up for your issue you will
wait your turn to lose our only hope our
only
and so what we saw in this deal two
weeks ago was Democrats headin into
September with a pretty strong hand
there were several must pass bills
including a debt ceiling they need to be
raised by the end of this month a short
term budget that need to be raised by
the end of this month and then Trump did
something really dumb and evil he attack
800,000 of the best that America has to
offer by saying that he was going to in
the daca program and a lot of advocates
thought hey we've got tools to respond
to this we have must pass legislation
that they need Democrats vote for the
next day Democratic leadership went into
the Oval Office cut a deal with the
white supremacist that left behind eight
hundred thousand dreamers and cleared
the September calendar if you're
wondering why we are discussing the
zombie Trump care bill right now it is
because of that deal so when we talk
about the importance of solidarity or
standing indivisible a lot of people
think of this is like the touchy-feely
everybody stand together kind of
rainbows and sunshine approach that's
that's part of it you got to stand up
for the most vulnerable communities but
that's not all of it it is a steely-eyed
strategy that if I don't stand up for
you I'm gonna lose and that's what we're
witnessing right now so when you talk
about cutting deals with Trump hey I'm
all for the butterflies and rainbows
veel if it's on the table if it's all
good stuff but we gotta stand for good
policy and if cutting a deal with Trump
winds up leaving 800,000 people behind
or endangering health care for 32
million Americans No thank you we're not
going to take those kind of deals
so I mean we had a little bit of our own
experience at Planned Parenthood when
you know just as an example I mean I
don't think this is maybe he is the many
he likes to make deals but I actually
don't think I think most of the stuff I
think to the point to be over making is
actually happening in Congress and is
happening in agencies where we have no
opportunity right and that's I think to
your point earlier is really important
because some of the most nefarious
things are happening where we don't get
to have a vote where it's it's you know
so I look at the Department of Health
and Human Services Tom Price who when
he's not flying on a private jet from
Washington DC to Philadelphia is
actually business did you hear about
this yeah yeah this doesn't take private
jets no I mean literally there they are
putting the sort of gears and motion to
execute a domestic gag order in this
country meaning that anyone who receives
national family planning dollars can no
longer advise women of their right to an
abortion refer them to an abortion
provider give them basic health care
information that is legal in America
that's the kind of thing that I'm
worried about is it a you know we're
mean we're following Donald Trump and
has crazy tweets and Twitter and in the
meanwhile they are unraveling health
care and rights for millions of folks
and that's just I feel like it's that's
gonna be the tough stuff is how do we
continue to how do we not take the bait
and focus on like the craziness over
here and really focus on I think to the
point everyone's made people in America
who are depending on government to be
there for them how does one respond to
that I mean if you've got you have to
you actually have to declare war on it
and you have to I mean you have to
completely shine a light on everything
that's happening and unfortunately
that's just what I think is gonna happen
right in a minute rave and doing this
it's like it's just no longer it's not
gonna be about bills it's about saying
what is happening to real people in this
country and lifting up their stories and
so when you begin to take away birth
control for 57 million people in this
country which Tom Price would like to do
when you take away the right to get
information about abortion we're not
gonna able to win that because he's in
charge but we can absolutely create the
biggest grounds
well movement ever seen on the rights to
reproductive health care in America and
that's what our job is right now to me
it has to be it's gonna have to be
calling it out as a well as well as
trying to win every everything we can I
just think the thing as folks are gonna
get I mean I don't know what y'all were
saying so you know people get tired
you're like the only so many times you
can call Congress and but that's when I
think we also just say when it when it
works so when you know when Donald Trump
was elected and when Paul Ryan came out
and said by January 27th they were gonna
have it they were gonna repeal Obamacare
and they were gonna defund Planned
Parenthood it's gonna be on the
President's desk boom okay well I don't
know what is today September or
something or other but it's like that's
you got to call a win a win and it
didn't happen it's not like it didn't
happen because they change their mind
it didn't happen because thousands and
thousands of people rose up and called
members of Congress and went to
Washington DC and wore their pink [ __ ]
hats to town hall meetings and and that
is so to me we also have to be able to
tell the story of what it means to
organize and actually win even if we're
not always going to win yeah so we sort
of already talked about this a little
bit but I kind of want to hone in it on
in it in on in it I don't know
specifically which is whether it's four
years from now in 2021 or eight years
from now in I don't know a year that is
regardless of whether it's four or eight
years
there's gonna be an after Trump period
there's gonna be weeks good yeah
hopefully sort of we're gonna be a post
Trump so in these questions for you
DeRay in that Africa moment the task
will be they'll be recovering will be
improving will be building something
anew so what for you does that look like
what does that work look like then what
what are the beginnings of that work now
to begin laying the groundwork for that
inevitability and what it what advice do
you have for people who other people who
are thinking towards the future like
when when this all passes what do we do
and how do we begin to get there yes sir
so closest to me are issues a mass
incarceration and police like we can
live in a world where the police don't
kill people I believe that we can live
in a row and we don't lock people up and
put people in cages as a as a matter of
what we call rehabilitation that's not
real like I believe those things I'm
also mindful that it's people of color
we often get pegged as mass
incarceration is like our only issue
right and like we live in a world where
more the mass incarceration affects us
so what does it look like they're like
everybody has access to health care and
they can like actually play in their
parent and that's like a real thing
right like people know what power looks
like at the local and state level like
that's a real thing so in terms of
building and I think that part of it is
with the mass incarceration space it is
taking away all the bad stuff I just
went to Angola which is the biggest
prison in the country it is 18,000 acres
it is is 28:28 square miles
18,000 acres it used to be four
plantations that is now one in the Cook
County Jail the largest deal in the
country used to house 18,000 people now
houses about 10,000 people which is wild
and you think about things like bail
reform and people talk about bail reform
is it's like mythical magical thing that
like can never happen and then you think
like DC got write a bail of decade ago
Kentucky doesn't have Bayonne New Jersey
every debate acog oh is ending bail
right now like we can actually do those
things right and like you just don't
hear about them some focus on those and
then it's like the quiet trauma so we're
trying to map that stuff so like
Louisiana and Oregon they're the only
two states that have what we call non
unit